there you go providing the good news in
what is a pretty bleak news day uh we're
gonna go to the commons now uh and hear
from the transport secretary grant shaft
in the past
mr speaker from 4 am on the 11th of
february and in time for the half term
break
eligible fully vaccinated passengers
arriving in the uk will no longer have
to take a post-arrival lateral flow test
that means that after months of
pre-departure testing post-arrival
testing self-isolation additional
expense all that fully vaccinated people
will now have to do when they travel to
the uk is to verify their status via a
passenger locator form
and mr speaker we promised we wouldn't
keep these measures in place a day
longer than was necessary and it's
obvious to me now that border testing
for vaccinated travelers has outlived
its usefulness and we're therefore
scrapping all travel tests for
vaccinated people
not only making travel much easier but
also of course saving about 100 pounds
per family on visits abroad providing
certainty to passengers to carriers and
vital tourism sector for the spring and
the summer seasons and so mr speaker let
me explain to the house how this will
actually work in practice
for now we'll maintain our current
definition of fully vaccinated for the
purposes of inbound travel to the uk and
that means two doses of an approved
vaccination or one dose of a jensen
vaccine and we'll go further
the measures for those arriving in the
uk who do not qualify
as fully vaccinated have not changed
since last march
so the time has come to review that
position too and today i can announce
that passengers who do not qualify as
fully vaccinated will no longer be
required to do a day eight test after
arrival or indeed to self-isolate
they will still need to fill out a
passenger locator form to demonstrate
proof of a negative covert test taken
two days before they travel they must
still take a post-arrival pcr test this
is a proportionate system that moves us
a step closer to normality while
maintaining vital public health
protections
now for kids traveling to the uk
under-ratings will continue to be
treated as eligible fully vaccinated
passengers which means they will not
face any tests at the uk border
and today i'm pleased to confirm that
from february the 3rd
12 to 15 year old
in england will be able to prove their
vaccination status via the digital nhs
pass for international outbound travel
again this should help families plan
holidays for february half term
and mr speaker reconnecting with key
markets not only to boost the uk economy
but will also help hard hit aviation
sector to take back to the skies so i
can also confirm that from 4am on the
11th of february we'll recognize at the
uk border vaccine
certificates from 16 further nations and
that will include countries like china
and mexico bringing the vaccine
recognition total to over 180 countries
and territories worldwide
mr speaker one of the consequences of
kovid and a rapidly changing infection
patterns across the world has been the
border regime that while necessary has
at times been complex and confusing and
very difficult to navigate i know it's
been something of a challenge for many
people who have been traveling over the
last two years so we're also going to
simplify the passenger locator form
making it quicker and easier to complete
and from the end of february we'll also
make it more convenient by giving people
an extra day to fill out the form before
they travel
and whilst the option for a red list of
countries will remain in place to
provide a first line of defense against
future covert variants of concern
arriving from other countries
we are looking to replace the managed
quarantined system
with other contingency measures
including home isolation provided we can
develop new ways to ensure high levels
of compliance
in the meantime our contingency measures
remain available and as the house knows
there are no countries on the red list
currently but i must make clear there
are only likely to be used these
contingency measures will only be
applied uh if
we are particularly concerned about a
variant of concern that poses a
substantial risk one which is even
greater than omkron in other words
now the uk health security agency will
continue to monitor threats and will
maintain a high effective surveillance
capacity monitoring covert infections
overseas but i can announce today that
over time we intend to move away from
blanket border measures to a more
sophisticated and targeted global
surveillance system i'm also committing
today to develop a full toolbox of
contingency options to provide more
certainty on how we respond against
future variants
the government will set out our strategy
including how we'll deal with any new
and future new strains of the virus next
month and we'll continue to work with
international partners including the
world health organization to help all
countries achieve a level of genomic
sequencing to monster variants which is
much closer to our own world leading
capacity mr speaker we're moving into a
new phase of the fight against covert
instead of protecting the uk from a
pandemic our future depends on us living
with endemic covet just as we live with
flu for example
so we'll set out our strategy for that
transition this spring but as we n
navigate our recovery and as we return
to more normal travel next month our
advice to all eligible adults who have
not been vaccinated vaccinated stays the
same please get jabbed as soon as
possible and if you had two jabs please
get boosted and i've been speaking mr
speaker to a lot of my opposite numbers
around the world recently and they've
made clear to me that regardless of what
we do they are very likely to require
the booster jab by this summer and so my
advice to anyone who wishes to travel
this year including during the summer is
don't leave it too late to get your
booster you're very likely to be
required it by the third party third
country that you're flying to
mr speaker we already have one of the
most open economies and societies in
europe with the result with the result
being that our gdp has outpaced that of
other g7 countries with these changes
today we've one of the most open travel
sectors in the world of course we know
that covid can spring surprises but
everybody now should feel confident
about booking holidays business trips
and visits to family and friends abroad
but be in no doubt mr speaker
it's only because the government got the
big calls right
on vaccination on boosters on dealing
with omicron and we can now open travel
and declare that britain is open for
business today we are setting britain
free mr speaker and i commend the
statement to the house